sin duda estas noticias que rodean la
contraofensiva en la que las fuerzas
ucranianas buscan recuperar esos
territorios que han sido ocupados por
los rusos no solamente desde la invasión
a gran escala del año pasado sino 2014
le ha quitado atención a la batalla por
esta población de por la cual los rusos
vienen luchando desde hace 10 meses sin
lograr todavía tener su control total
hemos hablado con varias tropas que
pelean dentro de la ciudad hemos hablado
con ellas a las afueras de allí en
poblaciones donde salen a descansar y
nos han contado por ejemplo que la
batalla continúa que los rusos tienen
gran parte del control de la ciudad pero
que sigue habiendo presencia ucraniana
nos dicen que una de las dos rutas que
tenían de acceso a la ciudad está
perdida la otra es una ruleta rusa la
que está bajo el alcance de la
artillería de las tropas de Moscú y que
son atacados permanentemente hablábamos
con unidad de drones que van todos los
días a la ciudad a trabajar y a realizar
sus misiones y nos contaban que a pesar
de que tienen un carro blindado todos
los días son atacados a la entrada o a
la salida tanto por artillería o por
armas más livianas otros también nos
cuenta que van hasta allí a pelear con
armas por ejemplo antitanques y a
detener el avance de las fuerzas de
Moscú que parece estar estar
acelerando lo más que pueden para
presentar bakmut como una victoria en
esa gran desfile militar que se realiza
en Moscú todos los nueves de mayo y que
tendrá este año la presencia no
solamente de Vladimir Putin sino de
tropas que pelean en Ucrania
especialmente en la región del donbas
allí también nos dicen que están a la
expectativa de saber Por cuánto tiempo
más pueden sostener
a la espera de lo que digan los
comandantes y la presidencia ucraniana
pero dicen que por el momento a pesar de
las dificultades sigue teniendo
presencia ucraniana